kids get to pop corner let me tell you  the story of the space viking thor  odinson  he was no ordinary man  he was a god  after saving planet earth for the 500th  time thor set off on a new journey  well he got in shape  he went from dead bod  to god bod  and after all that  he reclaimed his title  as the one and only thor  oh spook too soon  jane  [Music]  the old ex-girlfriend  what's a family three four years  eight years seven months and six days  give or take  my uh sensing feelings  [Music]  well you're right  the only ones who gods care about  is themselves  so this is my vow  all gods will die  i just must say that was very very  impressive what you did back  there he's just my first bad guy  you never forget your  [Music]  not like the first gods earth kill  because i have something worth fighting  for  [Music]  let's see who you are and take off your  disguise  and flick  oh you flick too hard damn it  should we help him mean eventually grape  [Music]  [Music]  you